-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-
and Golden Globe-winning
comedian
you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
"Palm Springs,"
and as one third
of The Lonely Island.
New episodes of his animated
series "Digman!" per-- per--
premiere -- oh, my God --
premiere Wednesday nights
at 10:30 on Comedy Central.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Andy Samberg.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-Yeah.
What a reaction.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is a big deal.
It has been a while since
you've been here in person.
And, in fact, the last time
you were here in person,
we were doing a cast show
for "Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
the series finale
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
-That's right.
-And the night before,
we were supposed to have dinner,
me, you, and Shoemaker, and I
called you guys and I said,
"I can't go to dinner because
Alexi just went into labor,"
and we had a baby girl
that night.
Now, there was a fear
that I wouldn't be able
to come and host the show
the next day.
But your whole cast
had flown out.
We knew we had to do the show.
You were gonna host the show.
-Yes, I got a call
from Shoemaker being like,
"Hey, will you host
the show tomorrow?"
I said, "Of course."
Easy-peasy.
I was all excited.
I got all this stuff prepped.
-Oh, you prepped things
for hosting the show?
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, truth be told,
I've kind of had my eye
on it for a while.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, to take over?
-Yeah, it was --
it was, like, kind of a hostile
takeover I had planned.
And then I was all, "Here's
my moment ready to seize."
-Okay, gotcha.
So what sort of planning
had you put into this?
-I had full segments
planned out.
-Oh, really? And you weren't
gonna use existing segments?
-No, no, no.
I was gonna blow that all up.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-All-new brand-new material.
-Inspired by anything?
-Nope.
-Totally unique?
-Yep, just original --
original ideas that I had.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-You want to share any?
-I mean, yeah.
It looks like you're
not gonna leave, so...
[ Laughter ]
...I guess I'll just burn them.
Okay, here's a couple of ideas
I had that I was gonna try out.
-Okay.
-One of them was called
"Jokes Andy Can't Tell."
-Okay. So, now,
we do have a segment
called "Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
-Yeah, but this is different.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-What's this one?
-So it would be like a series
of jokes that I can't tell.
But it's not because
they're inappropriate.
It's because
they all contain words
that I don't know
how to pronounce.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so you have to, like,
bail on them
'cause you just can't do it.
-Yeah, it would be like,
"What's the deal with
wors-i-sis-shire sauce?"
You know?
And then, like, goofy jokes
like, you know,
what did one sea en-a-manem-ony
say to the -- while
it was eating a "gy-ro"?
[ Laughter ]
-You can't say "gy-ro"?
-You say it.
-Alright. "Hee-ro."
-"Yee-ro."
-Oh, well there you go.
So you can tell it.
-Broke the fourth wall.
-Any other ideas?
-Oh, God. So many.
So, yeah, I had another idea
called "Guess What I Ate,"
where I take a bite of food
and then a celebrity guest
smells my breath
and they guess what I ate.
-I don't think people
would like that.
-No, they would've liked it.
And then I had another one
called "Should I Be Worried?"
And that would be I would invite
a dermatologist on the show
and show them all of my moles
and then after each one
be like, "Should I be worried?"
-And you think that would be
something, like,
people at home would enjoy?
-Oh, it would have been
on a T-shirt in no time.
Yeah.
What else?
Oh, I had another one where
famed cue card holder Wally
and I just gently kiss
for two minutes.
-Okay, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. So that's like
a time filler.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What's that?
-I'm sorry. Are you saying you
can't hear over the applause?
-I couldn't hear
over the applause, yeah.
-Okay, gotcha.
Yeah. Yeah.
-Anyway, that one's
self-explanatory.
And then I had another one
called "Punch or Hug."
-Okay.
-And I would just
go through the audience
and give each person
the opportunity
to either punch or hug me.
-Okay.
-And honestly, Seth, that one,
it's like whatever they feel
that they most need
for their emotional health.
You know, I'm just happy
to be of service.
-That's very modern.
Yeah.
-Yeah. Let's see.
Oh, I also had a desk piece
that I tested out in my mind
called "The Spitroast,"
where I just eviscerated
newsworthy topics
straight to their face.
-Well, that's kind of similar
to "Ya Burnt,"
which is a segment we have.
-What's that?
-Well, that's --
that's my sketch I do.
It's a sketch called "Ya Burnt,"
where we roast people,
you know, things.
-I don't know what that is,
but it sounds bad,
but this idea was a good idea.
Here, I'll show you.
Take a look.
[ Sizzling ]
Welcome to the barbecue pit...
where we've got a bunch
of suckling little piggies
and one long spit
to roast them on.
First up, the Charmin bears.
Hey, Charmin bears, I think
you need to see a doctor.
Nobody's supposed to spend
that much time in the bathroom.
IBS is a disease,
not a personality.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I've never seen
any of you wash your hands.
You guys are [bleep] gross.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Yeah.
If you knew how goddamn
disgusting you sounded
talking about [bleep]
all the time,
you'd put a gun in your mouth
and blow
your [bleep] brains out.
Hey, Charmin bears, time to take
the apple out of your mouth,
because ya spit-roasted.
[ Sizzling ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Like, it sort of started
with some details
about the Charmin bear.
Then it just got,
like, really --
You, like, really
went at them hard.
-Yeah, well, you know,
I don't pull punches.
-Also, that is totally
the same thing as "Ya Burnt."
-Yeah, again,
I don't know what that is.
"Ya Blurt."
What --
What words are you even saying?
To me it sounds like gibberish.
-I should just move on.
Do you have another?
-It's funny you ask,
'cause I do have one more.
[ Laughter ]
And I think we have time.
-Okay. Yeah.
So you'd be very good
at this job,
'cause a lot of it is knowing
whether or not there's time.
Knowing, like, "Oh,
we got to go to commercial
'cause they pay the bills."
You know?
-Don't say that.
Peek behind the curtain.
No big deal.
That's free of cost.
So, okay, you know
how you do "A Closer Look"?
-I do, Yeah.
-Pbht!
[ Laughter ]
The thing that you --
The thing that you olds
don't understand about...
-Olds?
-...about my online generation
is that we don't have
the attention span
for a 45-minute deep dive
into triangular arbitrage
or whatever.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
First of all, you're like
only five years younger than me.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
Man, you should moisturize more.
So that's a harsh burn.
-I got spit-roasted.
-You got spit-roasted.
Where's the camera?
Spit-roasted.
-[ Laughs ]
-Anyways, instead of
"A Closer Look,"
I would take a grosser look.
-Okay.
-Seth's nightmare-inducing
hell spawn Frisbee
continues to maintain
its identity as a dog
when it's clearly some sort
of rat-foreskin hybrid.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Grosser Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a dog.
This is not a dog.
[ Laughter ]
This is the worst greyhound
since the bus.
[ Laughter ]
If this dog took a dump,
I wouldn't know which was which
and flush them both
down the toilet.
[ Toilet flushes ]
This has been "A Grosser Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We'll be right back with more
from Andy Samberg.